comment on peut voir on avait deux silos
et puis il avait appris dans le premier
pile défecteux m'enchante au cap pierre
chaumont peine à croire ce qu'ils voient
plusieurs bâtiments sur sa ferme ont été
détruits par la tempête
tout d'abord cela a avancé de 2 pieds
sur ses fondations on peut voir la
fondation qui est là la grange à lever
puis à l'avancé les dommages sont
évalués à plusieurs centaines de
milliers de dollars selon lui un peu la
désolation le sait tous qu'il va venir
avec après tout les problèmes qui
viennent avec son fils travaille
l'agriculteur est père de famille n'aura
pas le choix que de se tourner vers sa
compagnie d'assurance puisque québec ne
prévoit pas d'indemniser les personnes
touchées il ya des assurances
individuelles par rapport aux maisons
donc mon époque on vit actuellement soit
les codes d'alimentation où les dégâts
sont les maisons c'est les assureurs qui
prennent le relais je pense que je suis
bien assurée mais j'espère que les gens
en général le sont aussi
à quelques kilomètres de la ferme
les équipes d'hydro-québec sont à
l'oeuvre depuis tôt ce matin à l'échelle
de la province mais le 200 techniciens
sont engagés dans une course contre la
montre ces seize heures par jour puis
c'est un 8 heures de repos que ça prend
pour l'ego c'est sous ce seuil un
minimum de stress de ses convives à
travailler sur mes coups que tout avec
ensemble en équipe le tout et
travailleurs plusieurs tests à l'effort
puis après ça se passe super bien déjà
60 % des foyers touchés par les pannes
de courant ont pu être rebranchés on
vise 80 % et rapidement le sont plus
rares dans les eaux 90 95 % hydro québec
ignore toujours à quel moment le courant
sera complètement de retour dans la
province puisque certaines zones sont
plus difficiles d'accès c'est sûr c'est
plus compliqué quand il ya beaucoup de
boizel comme j'expliquais de remonter le
fil quand il ya des arbres c'est assez
compliqué aussi le hydro québec demande
à la population d'éviter de s'approcher
des fils au sol il faut plutôt appeler
le 9-1-1 pour faire sécuriser les lieux
ici à diass in rats du cadam à sainte
anne des plaines